check one two
okay let's go ahead and get started
welcome to we actually have a number of
visitors at our usual Thursday
conference today a number of candidates
here interviewing for our ph.d program
for next year so they're here attending
along with the usual audience so we
welcome them so as you all know we often
do these two per one with faculty where
faculty give up use half of the time to
to give an overview of their work
we actually had only had one
presentation signed up for today but
that actually worked out well because at
noon she's not here yet but Sarah Biber
is coming some of you may know her she
used to work for cd28 she's actually now
she'll tell us her exact title something
like director of innovation in the
Department of Surgery
she is organizing it what is being
called an inventor thawne it's kind of
like a hackathon although it is broader
than just hacking and she would love to
get some student and faculty involvement
so I thought as long as we have you here
as a captive audience with the pizza
that I would have her come by and talk a
little bit about her work and then I
know that Karen and Heidi need to go so
I should introduce them quickly but
that's easy because most of you know
Karen and Heidi quite well they're both
professors in the department who
collaborate together on patient decision
aids in particular patient decision aids
around mammography and Karen has a PhD
from Portland State and engineering
management has been
on our faculty many years and same thing
with Heidi Nelson who has training in
medicine internal medicine and and
public health and has also been part of
demise for a long time so I will turn it
over to Karen so I'm really excited to
be here today to share with you a little
bit more about the tools we've been
creating and these tools are really
designed for for really patient and
clinicians and so how do you and I have
been partnering together on a number of
grants and we've actually worked with
Bill to actually integrate what you're
gonna see today with the electronic
health record and Ben I don't know if n
is here today but we have a very large
team that includes medical students
postdocs faculty our programmer
statisticians so as you can see we have
quite a large number of people Katie
Benson sponsored the work to be done in
her clinic in general internal medicine
so it's really exciting for that so we
have this what we're gonna be showing
you today actually was funded by a
knight center support grant and also NLM
training grant and before we get too far
let's before we get too far into the
tool that we're going to show you it's
very important to understand the
evidence that supports that tool and
Heidi is the expert in that area so dr.
Nelson here you go fantastic can you
hear me I don't know that this is even
on ok it's being recorded especially in
here I just want to know how hard to
talk i I'm not I know the biggest
loudest voice in the room
welcome to the candidates I hope you are
having a good day so far as my colleague
Karen in described this project had a
huge team and I think it's a perfect
example of collaboration across
different disciplines and across
different sciences so there's sort of a
niche for practically anybody in the
room and informatics as well as
clinicians
on the other side and it involves
patience so it's got a little bit
everybody involved but first off let's
just see if there other clinicians in
the room other people who see patients
so quite a few okay great great because
you're um those of you who see patients
understand the whole idea of
evidence-based medicine and how it takes
we don't just do things for patients
especially when it comes to screening or
other types of clinical guidelines those
have come about from a long process of
evaluating evidence research on whether
it works what are the problems what are
the harms the benefits who do we we
target what do we do there's a huge
evidence base that informs what we do
and that results in clinical guidelines
that everyone should be getting and
particularly in preventive services the
Affordable Care Act has a mandate that
all of the clinical prevention services
recommended by the US Preventive
Services Task Force Bright Futures for
children the CDC immunizations at a
newer group specifically for women the
women's preventive services initiative
those recommendations are covered with
no copay or deductible charge for
private and public insurance so we're
talking about 65 million women in
regards to mammography screening so it's
very important that people get it right
and that the right people get screened
they have their all covered they're all
have abilities to get the covered but
they only get covered because it works
and the harms are considered to be not
as important in the and the balancing
act of that with as the benefits so what
are the recommendations so what's
covered under the ACA based on uh both
recommendations from the u.s. preventive
services preventive services at the WPS
I and I informed both groups I do they
have been to review for both groups for
average-risk women initiate mammography
screening no earlier than age 40 and no
later than age 50 is the guideline so
you can start it by 40 but different
quality metrics in health systems will
start to look at you if you don't start
screening by 50 screen at least by
annually
so every other every two years but maybe
for some women annual is appropriate so
that's gonna vary so funders will pay
for annuals for certain people but
biannual for everybody continue at least
through age 74 and beyond that the
evidence fades out we don't have trials
of women older than that so age alone
should not be the basis to discontinue
screening but it's a little murky as to
how long you go with screening and how
do we know how to navigate all those
murky areas because those decisions
about when to initiate screening how
often to screen when to stop should be
based on periodic shared decision-making
that involves the woman in her
healthcare provider whoever that be it
could be nurse practitioner it could be
the physician the person primarily
involved with screening decisions that's
a lot to do with a shared
decision-making process so that's easy
to put out there in recommendations but
most clinicians go well what do I do
with that I have 10 things to address in
less than 10 minutes and then ography
screening is a pretty big issue when you
get to these gray areas so what do we
actually do with that and that's what
led to a decision aid and our
collaboration on making it something we
can do so most people don't realize not
only do women have access to mammography
screening there are two other preventive
services that involve cancer prevention
or screening that women have access to
as well that are covered under the ACA
and I haven't been involved in both of
these as well with the US Preventive
Services Task Force so one is risk
assessment genetic counseling and
genetic testing for pathogenic mutations
of brca1 and 2 genes which are the
cancer related genes and so we don't
test everybody even though testing
companies want us to do that we don't
test everybody we ask all women about
their family history for breast cancer
for us to know variant cancer and other
related cancers and there are short
tools that have been tested develop the
one we use we'll show you developed by
the CDC for this purpose triage is women
too
genetic counseling where they actually
spent an hour doing kindred analysis and
more sophisticated methods to really get
a good estimate but asking just a short
list of questions will get you into that
door or not and then women who have
those positive screening results go to
genetic counseling and if indicated
after counseling opted for it they can
go get their mutation testing so it's
done in the careful way we don't just
everybody's DNA so there's a third one
and this one's even harder for a lot for
women with increased risk of breast
cancer using medication tamoxifen
raloxifene aromatase inhibitor isn't
even more emerging Tenri can prevent
breast cancer the other things are for
reducing you know when you get to the
modern fee screening you're just finding
it early but when you actually give
people medications to reduce breast
cancer risk you're actually preventing
it so that's pretty amazing but only
women and increase risk so how do you
figure that out well it turns out
everyone has been defaulting to these
population-based risk assessment tools
like the Gail model who's heard of that
the problem is they were developed from
population data and when you apply them
to individuals they're about as good as
a coin flip in telling you who's gonna
get cancer they don't work clinically
they are inaccurate so whenever we say
well just you know you're Gail model
risk score that's actually what the FDA
says these people with a Gail score of
more than one point six six five-year
percent increase in risk of breast
cancer are can have these drugs
that's ridiculous how can we get that
kind of precision with a tool that's no
better than a coin flip so when you get
down to the reality of shared
decision-making and this risk assessment
it's pretty lame and so we want to not
make a tool that's lame
so we didn't we actually made something
we think has can hold up to the evidence
as we have today evidence hopefully
we'll get better as we go but I don't
see research really going in that
direction so what is a shared
decision-making and why is that part of
this shouldn't you know maybe the
clinician just sit there and scratch
their head and figure out these risk
factors well there's more to this than
just risk involved figuring out their
risk women have a lot of strong
preferences about their health care
especially when it comes to screening
screening you're taking healthy people
off the street and doing something and
we can do a lot of harm when we do that
inappropriately we can put people into a
category of disease that they didn't
know they had and maybe it doesn't even
mean anything or we can subject them to
biopsies and all kinds of things that
are expensive have complications so when
we screen people we have to be very
careful that we understand their
preferences they understand the risks
they may be assuming and that's what
your decision-making does this is a nice
diagram we often use in these talks to
just sort of lay out what is shared
decision-making it's a way to assist
women in making informed decisions and
of course everybody walking in the door
doesn't have a medical degree or a PhD
or training they have to understand in
their context of their own education
their their language barriers their
health education barriers we have to go
to where they are in discussing this and
that's not so easy to do quickly and
effectively but essentially what happens
you discuss the benefits and harms of
screening you assess the woman's values
and preferences and sometimes their
preferences are based on an incorrect
information that they got off the web
because that's always right right so
there's a lot of and you know my
girlfriend and my mom and you know
there's a lot of stuff around those
preferences that that need to maybe have
a reality check and then they consider
the factors that such as risk life
expectancy for screening those older
women when do we stop my grandmother
looked at 103 had no health problems so
when you know 75 was like her youth
comorbidities health status there are a
lot of things that go into this and so
if you have 10 minutes with a patient to
conquer 10 problems on the list this is
a big deal so we developed a screening
aid to get patients ready to walk in the
door they do most of the work online in
the waiting room that are at home
so we used a risk tool to identify if a
woman's above average or average risk
based on major risk factors and family
history the women above average risk in
the decision tool at the front end are
referred appropriately to genetic
counseling back to their clinician to
look at their loved the lump they
described in their breast they go
elsewhere they don't even go into the
decision aid because they have things to
attend to
women with avengers' continue going
through the decision aid component they
get educational material they set
priorities based on their own
understanding and preferences and then
they get a report that lists their
questions they have and the the things
that are important to them and gets them
ready to go in and talk to their
clinician and this can be printed if
they want to karen will be telling us in
a minute about our study that brings it
in to the electronic records and what
we're hoping to do with that in a future
study but that report shows all the work
that was done in this session and so
hopefully is gets people ready for that
encounter so we did a pilot study that
was funded by the knight Cancer Center
where we took our original more
prototype version and we updated it we
expanded that earlier version to include
all women under the recommendation up to
age 74 we did a connection with the
electronic health records and we did a
study that mostly took place in 2018 I
understand our paper is galley proof
stage as we speak so you couldn't
actually read about it your evening
reading at home whatever you I want to
see more about it but we looked at women
in 308 chess you internal medicine
primary care practices and they're big
on screening they have checklists are
very just screening and they it's
probably a quality measure in health
systems it's a heat us measure to screen
women above age 50 so the women in the
primary care practices were invited to
use our decision aid memo screen via my
chart which is the OHS new portal and we
collected data on feasibility uptake
experiences and then we compared data
that we got from mamuh screen with data
that's existing in the EHR say oh it's
in there we don't need to collect more
data well we
No is that true so we started in the
beginning I told you we tried to
integrate the risk factors so this is a
part of the process that I probably had
more involvement in since I did this all
for the u.s. task force and other groups
so we started with the big stuff we call
them the high risk flags rather than go
into calculator just give me a checklist
what's important so anybody who has
symptoms we don't need to go to the
decision aid you need to have those
symptoms looked at anybody with a
radiation history and there are no many
people like this but in a university
hospital system they're there more so if
they got treatment for Hodgkin's
lymphoma or other kinds of radiation
exposure they're at a high risk if they
have known BRCA mutations or relatives
with them we want to send them in a
different route if they have previous
breast or ovarian cancer they're not
really being screened they need to go to
surveillance mode not screening mode so
if they have any of these flags they get
a message if not they keep moving and
then we put them into we asked them
about previous breast biopsies if
they've had a high resolution or cancer
on a previous biopsy we need to send
them in a different direction many of
them don't know exactly what the outcome
was so we just kind of keep them moving
and maybe that needs to be checked if it
can be but we want to know who had a
high resolution because they're actually
being surveilled to they're not being
screened and then we go into the CDC
risk tool we need to know if they have
Ashkenazi Jewish heritage which is
associated with founder mutations of the
BRCA genes which can increase your risk
but also a series of questions developed
by the CDC about family history if they
score at a certain level they then need
to go on to genetic counseling and do a
kindred analysis otherwise you get
through all this off to the decision aid
and here's the mastermind behind the
rest
Thank You Heidi so actually I just want
to go back a slide because one of the
things that we wanted to really ensure
when we created our decision aid is that
the right people were using decision
aids so anybody who was considered above
average risk did not go on to see the
next pieces that you're going to see
they are the people who do go on to see
the decision aid are considered average
risk and they're in that purple that
lavender shaded shape up there okay so
let's let's now talk about decision aids
so decision aid is something that needs
to be written in plain language so that
everybody can understand it because you
see most people don't understand some of
the very complex medical terms that you
all know and so we want to be able to
know that they understood what we're
trying to convey so we do interviews
with patients we have them look at
different graphics we have them look at
our language and we ask them tell us in
your words what you see this figure in
um for example actually initially began
as one one figure in the middle and we
showed more aggressive you know bigger
lesion organs involved and we had one
side and be more aggressive one side
less aggressive until somebody said to
me they didn't realize that the left
side was much more risky so if you have
breast cancer in your left breasts you
have much more aggressive cancer so that
was not what we met so we went back to
our graphic artist and we said we need
to we can't have one figure we need to
have two figures to be able to convey
the same message everybody seemed to
understand the torus and the hair and
and they did understand that some
cancers grow slowly so grow grow fast
but they did you know we knew we wanted
to convey that that we can't tell you
with certainty how your cancer is going
to behave
okay so the next thing we tried a whole
bunch of graphics it was around what
happens when you go in to have a
mammogram well in general 4000 women who
are average risk go in to have a
mammogram and there let's say they're in
their 40s
875 would be told they have normal
results 874 would not have cancer but
there would actually be one cancer
missed so initially when we wrote this
out we just said one cancer
we didn't say one cancer missed and so
then we showed the two different
versions to the patients and one patient
said oh this is alarming they missed
this cancer
well actually the figure before it was
the same they actually missed it that
figure too we just didn't say is missed
and so that's where it's really
important to test your product with
patients so that they understand what
your you're trying to convey now let's
look at the pink the pink circle there
125 women are gonna get that dreaded
phone call we see something that we
don't really know we'd like you to come
back in and do more tests and what what
would come out of that is of the hundred
and twenty-five 121 do not have cancer
there would be two cancers found and two
pre-cancers found and this is all based
on the work that dr. Nelson has done so
all these numbers that you see in the
decision aid have evidence behind them
so next we wanted to know if you send a
MyChart message to a patient invite them
to use this risk tool and decision aid
would they actually do it you know and
it actually came from the clinic had the
physicians name on it
had the clinic name on it so there was
some personalization so the patient knew
all my clinic is participating in this
and what we found is that 76 percent
would open there my chart message now we
enrolled people who had enrolled in my
chart we know that some people enroll in
my chart but never opened their messages
so we lost 24 percent right off the bat
but at least 76 percent open the message
then we wanted to know of those who open
their message how many of them would
enroll they actually would complete the
consent and then click the link to go
into the risk tool and the decision aid
we were very pleased
that for those who consented and started
using mammoth screen they finished 94
percent completed we did lose some
people at the consent stage and one of
the things that we've now worked with
the IRB we had to show at that time a
three page single-spaced consent form
well not very many people want to read
through all of that and I think they
thought that was the decision aid so now
yeah that was not the decision aid so
now will be when we implement this in an
in the future we'll be able to show just
some bulleted summary and they can click
on the link to see the full three page
single-spaced consent form but they
don't have to read that they can get the
main points son so we we explained to
the IRB this really was a barrier but
now we think that will will be reduced
so well who were the people that
completed mantle screen well we had
thirty forty to forty nine year olds
eighty eight fifty to seventy four year
olds we didn't have a very diverse
clinic that particular clinic isn't as
diverse as we would have liked we do
have ideas and we have talked with some
clinics that primarily have for example
Spanish speakers to translate to Spanish
and deploy in a more diverse clinic so
next we wanted to know what was their
experience did they spend a lot of time
with this well actually no most people
spent on average about four minutes
going through the risk algorithm for
somebody who was very low risk and said
no to all the parent questions they
probably got through in two minutes for
someone who indicated yes someone in my
family had breast cancer then they would
have to go through and indicate you know
how many and what age they were you know
were they under 50 or older than 50 so
that the person who has a family history
of breast cancer probably spend a little
more time than four minutes for what for
those people who went on to use our
decision aid they actually only really
used it for two to three minutes it was
a very quick experience which is what we
really wanted because you know we may be
deploying this at times even in the
waiting room and it's not gonna delay a
patient going in to appointments okay so
then we also interviewed the patients to
find out well what was their experience
and what they what they said is that it
was highly intuitive they decision aid
and the and the risk algorithm was easy
to navigate but for most of them it
didn't change their screening intentions
however this particular clinic had a
pretty high mammography rate to begin
with seven of eight participants would
recommend mammoth screen particularly to
women who are a little bit less
knowledgeable about whether they want to
be screened and understanding their
risks and benefits and maybe less
knowledgeable but their own family
history we then interviewed the three
physicians and the MA we wanted to make
sure that what we created didn't create
extra burden on the clinical workflow we
worked very carefully to make sure that
it was you know it was implemented kind
of invisibly and it was natural to the
workflow they felt the patients were
more informed about their own health
they felt it aligned with the use with
the use of technology in health care
they really wanted to see it be
synchronized with an upcoming visit
which is how we actually envisioned it
early on was that you would have a
patient do it prior to coming into a
visit the other thing that we had to
learn was not every physician wanted to
see every report of every patient and so
that's part of what we're trying to do
as we move forward with integrating with
EHR you know really some one physician
wanted to see every report one physician
only wanted to see see the patients who
had symptoms and were above average risk
and not being screened and so there is a
bit of customization in terms of what
kind of information flows to the
physicians what information do they want
to see what was important to each one of
them and I think there's ability to do
that so the next thing we did is we took
the hundred and eighteen women who
completed Mammal screen and we said well
let's see what was in the charts before
they use mammal screen and let's see how
hard it is to find that information and
what we found is that information was
missing it was conflicting and it was
difficult to find perhaps it might have
been a little note might have gone in a
progress note that said something like
mother was just diagnosed with breast
cancer but maybe that information never
gets into the family history cell it's
just it's just sitting in a progress
note somewhere much most of the
information wasn't structured and we
also learned that eight women reported
symptoms using manual screen and one of
those eight actually was a new symptom
and it was not nothing was recorded in
her chart so it was important to reach
out the clinical staff immediately
reached out to have this particular
patient come in for follow-up all right
so as you as dr. Nelson mentioned there
were two categories so after using the
risk algorithm you either fell into the
category of a better average risk or
above average risk and what we found is
there was only agreement I don't know if
I have an arrow here well there was only
agreement on for seven patients so there
were 21 patients who were above average
risk when using either mammal screen or
according to the chart and that we
applied the same exact algorithm to the
chart so we treated them exactly the
same only seven were found in both so
you could look in the chart and see it
but not conveniently there's nothing in
there that says above average risk you'd
have to go in and count up the number of
family members who had breast cancer
however in chart review there were eight
women that were considered above average
risk and then but but in terms of the
mammal screen there were 13 total in
terms of chart review 15 total for an
overall number of 21 so what that told
us is that you really need both pieces
of information to get a comprehensive
understanding of whether this patient is
above average risk we did provide the
overall agreement and the Kappa
coefficient was only moderate but as I
said we were really focused in on those
women who were above average risk we
wanted to know what the agreement was
for those women
so what we concluded is that it was
feasible to deploy this in clinics um
and in fact this very clinic has signed
on with us with the latest grant that we
just put in in February the uptake was
76% of those who opened the invitation
36 percent and rolled and the experience
was brief it was 6 minutes for those who
use both the risk tool and the decision
aid so that's not a long period of time
and it provides more timely and more
complete breast cancer risk information
the clinicians want to know who the
women are in their clinics who are above
average risk so they can reach out and
appropriately have conversations about
preventive measures and right now it's
very difficult to do because the
information is not stored in a way that
they can look at a chart and say oh this
person's above averages quickly for some
yes but for many no and I think that's
it so questions for Heidi and I here
comes the microphone I guess my question
is about the risk model itself you
should have some good photos there and I
was wondering is that all clicking on
one or another or another is there a box
to fill in my half-sister my cousin out
of breast cancer or I have a gene
mutation but it's not brca1 or brca2
yeah now the that's a really great
question the the risk tool that we just
showed you one box there's a series of
family history questions that come from
the CDC tool so essentially they're just
do these relatives have breast ovarian
cancer and it goes to maternal and
paternal sides so you know the various
different relatives and any any clicking
of one or of two if you get sort of a
threshold of two buys your referral so
it's a triage tool it's not a way of
estimating familial cancer risk then the
earlier question go to third degree
relatives and just wonder if it goes
first a second
yeah so it's kind of a you know a quick
way to get at least the the tip of the
iceberg
people are missed either way but
different studies by the CDC's study
group showed that it's pretty good it's
pretty accurate it's better than not
asking then the other one about BRCA we
just said BRCA as one of those big flags
but the question is do you or your
relatives have an own ESA one mutation
or and I think there's some language
about other genetic mutation but to list
all of the possibilities this kind of
goes over everybody's head so people who
know no but it probably does it doesn't
drill down to any other types of
mutations but we're increasingly finding
more and more that linked in so it's
evolving I wanted to just add we had a
lot of does Heidi and I had a lot of
discussion about what mez how what
messages to convey to patients and we
really felt that conveying numbers at
times could be confusing because
sometimes people think oh any number
bigger than one I'm at huge risk
well maybe not and so that's why we use
we took this approach with this model to
put people into above average or average
and really to give them very practical
next steps and not just here's your
number many people don't know what to do
with that any other questions
dr. Aybar do you have any plans to
incorporate I was just hearing that how
there's no recommendations for you know
there's still not good evidence on who
needs an MRI so both most primary care
clinicians are defer to the radiologist
if there needs to be a better view but
as far as a screening algorithm or
recommendation the evidence is just not
strong enough it's it's shows increased
detection but is that increased
mortality or decrease you know what does
it do and what are the ups and downs and
there still hasn't been a good trial
showing us that yeah I was reviewer for
that study that just came out it's
increased detection again that's helpful
but how does that fit in with the whole
screening thing so I know as you know
it's working health systems that
deferred to radiologists they need a
good view they need something else who's
gonna hold them back from that but as
far as what do we do at the front end
it's still really mammography okay they
want you to go to Tomah right away and
get everything right away usually is
yeah yeah yeah they want when I go
everybody wants me to go right to Tomo
and no you pay extra it's not covered ac
will cover digital mammography
but there's no more questions I think I
should hand off to our next speaker Phil
will introduce